we were talking about what everyone's
been talking about for days now and it's
law enforcement on alert Nationwide
after former president Trump called for
his supporters to protest today Trump's
language of course Echoes his comments
in the run-up to the January 6 Riot and
as a result extra barricades are now in
position around the criminal court in
lower Manhattan where Trump could be
indicted in connection to a hush money
payment to an adult film star security
has also been increased at the U.S
Capitol with new barricades and extra
patrols Robert Costa is outside the
court in New York here uh Bob good
morning
Good morning Tony Trump's Republican
allies are now going after the district
attorney leading this investigation all
as the protection around this court is
on display
steel barricades were brought into Lower
Manhattan after former president Donald
Trump predicted his arrest and called
for protests inside the courthouse the
grand jury continued its work on Monday
hearing from the potential Final witness
he's totally unreliable attorney Bob
Costello a longtime Trump Ally was
brought in to testify about Cohen's
credibility Cohen was Trump's former
fixer and a key witness in this
investigation if they want to go after
Donald Trump and they have solid
evidence so be it but Michael Cohn is
far from solid evidence it was Cohen who
made the alleged hush money payments to
Stormy Daniels in the final days of the
2016 campaign he later pleaded guilty to
felony charges related to that payout
this has many similarities to a mob case
for the main witness to have problems
blemishes even convictions and it will
fall to the prosecution to say sure
Michael Cohen has some issues but he
here is why you can believe him many
House Republicans are defending the
former president and or calling on New
York district attorney Alvin Bragg to
submit testimony on what they call a
politically motivated prosecutorial
decision some bookkeeping Heir from
seven years ago is misdemeanor is now
now makes absolutely no sense
and Florida Governor Ron DeSantis a
potential 2024 rival to Trump criticized
the D.A but also had this to say I don't
know what goes into paying hush money to
a porn star to to secure silence over
some type of alleged Affair I just I
can't speak to that
CBS News has learned that an indictment
of trump is not expected today but could
come sometime later this week meanwhile
Trump's campaign has been issuing a
flurry of fundraising appeals to his
supporters Gail
Bob thank you very interesting comments
from Rhonda Santos and he said it with a
straight face it provided better humor
yesterday afternoon thank you very much
Bob Costas